let's compare the fraction
four
sevenths
to the fraction five-sevenths
and what i want you to do right now is
to pause this video and think about
which of these fractions represents a
larger quantity
i'm assuming you've had to go at it and
the one thing that might jump out at you
is that they both have the same bottom
number which we call the denominator
they both have a denominator of seven so
one way to think about it this is
literally four sevenths this is
literally five seven so we could rewrite
four sevenths as literally four
times one seventh
and we can rewrite five sevenths as
literally five times one-seventh
it's five sevenths
5 7.
so now if i have 4 of something versus 5
of something which is going to be a
larger quantity well clearly 5 of this 1
7 is going to be more
so 4 7 is smaller 5 7 is larger
and so what we can do is we can write a
less than symbol the way that i remember
less than and greater than is that the
point the small side of the symbol
always is on the same side as a smaller
number so this could be read as 4 7 is
less than 5 7 or that 4 times 1 7 is
less than 5 times 1 7.
now let's do another scenario but
instead of having the same denominator
let's have the same
numerator so let's say we want to
compare
let's say we want to compare
three
fourths
versus
three
versus three
over let's say versus three over
nine
which of these two fractions is a larger
number and once again pause the video
and try to think about it on your own
well as we as as we mentioned we don't
have the same denominator here we have
the same top number instead here is the
same bottom number same denominator here
we're going to have the same numerator
we have the three right over there and
we could view three fourths as literally
three
times one-fourth
and we could view three-ninths as
literally three times one-ninth
three
times
three times one-ninth
so we have three-fourths and we have
three-ninths so we really just have to
think about what's larger a fourth or a
ninth
well think about if you start with a
hole think about starting with a hole
like this
think about starting with a hole let's
draw a and let me make a hole right over
here
a hole
right over here so the same sized hole a
fourth is literally taking the hole and
dividing it into four pieces while the
ninth is taking the whole and dividing
into nine nine equal sections i could
say so let's divide this into four equal
sections
so
my best attempt to hand draw equal
sections
so that's two equal sections and then
that looks pretty close to four equal
sections so that right over there is
one-fourth and let me draw ninths here
so let me first put this into three
equal sections so those would be third
and then split each of those into three
equal sections
so this is my best
attempt at that
at hand drawing nine equal sections
splitting the hole into nine equal
sections so when you see here you might
have already realized this if you divide
something into four equal sections each
section is going to be bigger than if
you divide it into nine equal sections a
ninth is smaller than a fourth a ninth
is smaller than one-fourth so
three-ninths is going to be smaller than
three-fourths so once again when you
want to do less than or greater than you
want to put the point the small side of
the symbol on the same side as a smaller
number so it would look like this and
this is the greater than symbol because
you're literally what you have on the
left is the larger number three-fourths
is greater than three-ninths and if you
actually wanted to represent not just
one-fourth and one-ninth we could
actually color it in three times
one-fourth well that's one
two
three
while three times one-ninth or
three-ninths is one
two
three and when you look at it that way
it's pretty clear but the the important
thing to realize is is that when the
denominator is larger when the
denominator is larger you're dividing
the whole into more pieces so each piece
will be smaller so making the
denominator larger makes the fraction
smaller making the numerator larger
makes the fraction larger